have you heard when it comes to how we
think gender doesn't matter there seems
to be no purely male brains versus
female brains
there is no difference I've been
skeptical of that claim for years aren't
women in general better nurturers no
next question when Google engineer James
d'amour merely suggested that gender
differences might explain why we don't
have 50% representation of women in tech
he was fired in the culture war those
who claim total equality are winning
that seems to be quite lots of you
professor Gina Ripon just wrote this
book that says neurosciences shattered
the myth of the female brain I've
certainly been talking to full houses in
Denmark there was 1200 people and 500
people on a waiting list in America two
people crowd into auditoriums to hear
rip on explain just how different all
the sexes sex isn't an important
differentiate with respect to brains and
brain structures it doesn't look as
though it is it's important to get that
message out says rip on so people don't
mindlessly follow stereotypes you don't
want an idea that this is something
that's natural it's not natural that in
school more boys want to play football
and more girls wanted to do ballet
well I want to run and bang into people
and I'm bored by béla actually girls
might want to run and bang into people
but because there's an image that girls
don't do that they're stopped from doing
that so thank you very much for
listening and that's what today's
audiences want to hear we must fight it
together thank you but in my reporting
I've covered research that shows big
differences for example tests show most
men have better spatial awareness
students are blindfolded and then walked
through the maze of tunnels that run
underneath the campus when the women are
asked where a college building is you
tell me where Wilson Commons is they're
not so sure Valley men however retained
a sense of what direction they've moved
go through the next doors take women on
the other hand have a better memory for
detail those students are asked to wait
in a cluttered room while an
experimenter gets something ready how
much of the room will she remember on
the right hand side of the desk right
here was a briefcase with your initials
at the top women typically give answers
like this in the middle there was
envelopes York University envelopes
there was a thing at Clearasil Bazooka
Joe comic men were more likely to say I
don't know some stuff I don't have a
very good memory of course they might
have been molded by our sexist society
except the tests on infants also find
differences baby boys look longer at
objects like tractor parts infant girls
stare at faces girls looked at the face
and boys more likely looked at the
object if you look very closely at the
data a third of the girls actually seem
to respond more to the tractor parts
than the boys 1/3 1/3 2/3 didn't so
let's do it again with the biggest set
of newborns a better controlled set of
stimuli the media are clearly on rip
onside seems like we're just not that
different after all
but many scientists will tell you our
brains are not basically the same you
can tell looking at brains whether or
not they belong to a male or a female
80% of the time evolutionary
psychologist Diana Fleischman cultures
around the world show very similar
differences between men and women men
are more likely to seek status women are
more likely to take care of children
women are more likely to stay in the
home men are more likely to do dangerous
aggressive things like go to war
because we men have been socialized
works important and you women have been
told by your mothers say take care of
the kids why would you see that across
every culture in the world
maybe because cultures have always
encouraged men to behave this way we are
the same until society influences us and
you look at if you look at non-human
animals if you look at monkeys they
don't have culture and yet there's still
these very large differences between
males and females among scientists
that's majority opinion neuroscience
cited 70 studies that found differences
boys are more likely to be autistic
colorblind and have speech problems I
stutter most stutterers are boys it's
not a brain difference there are those
kinds of brain differences and I'm
definitely not a brain difference denial
that's kind of how you've been presented
by much of the media indeed indeed
perhaps I haven't read the book I bet
the headline writers didn't on the other
hand Sheena rippln seems to be a sex
difference denier depending on kind of
what audience that she's talking to I
thinking there's a difference between
men and women deep like me stand up and
say actually no this not is an
incredibly alluring message it's really
sad that it's not right is this a really
good message that we should be sending
out to everybody that there are profound
or fundamental differences shouldn't
matter whether it's a good message it
should just be science what the truth is
but science is is not as neat as people
like to think that hasn't stopped
politicians and businesses from
demanding gender equality BBC announced
that it wants an equal number of men and
women we reaffirmed our commitment to
advance gender equality because
politicians say men and women are the
same if women are paid less it must be
sexism the pay gap and the wage gap is
an injustice unfortunately a lot of
scientists people like Gina Rippon have
made it seem like yes there should be
gender parity but you do see that men
and women have different interests by
arguing this you perpetuate stereotypes
sexism saying that men and women have
different aptitudes isn't sexism it's
actually a statement about the true
nature of the world
if we keep saying that those differences
in what men and women choose to do are
because of sexism nobody's going to end
up happy with what they're doing and
we're gonna keep making laws to remedy
what's actually just the results of
freedom